[Music]
[Applause]
he's nick wright first things first
co-host on fox sports one also has a
podcast that he does uh what's right
with nick wright that he does with his
son and he joins us on the program hi
nick
hi dan every time i come on you guys are
talking about some golf course you're
going to play whenever this happened
last time too well i've played it todd
we were talking about tiger maybe trying
to play augusta yeah and then i talked
about walking it and it's a lot hillier
than what people think when you're
watching on tv and so then see that's
why people come to you for the first
hand xc i could never do that yeah i
couldn't you know can i can i reveal
something here i'm in fact i'm not even
asking i'm gonna do it so dan and i are
actual friends now we had dinner
together i'm sure he's talked to you all
about it quite a bit it was a wonderful
time
and there's nothing that you know every
once in a while my ego needs a resetting
and i got it at this meal because i walk
into this fancy steakhouse stand invites
me to
and he and i are walking towards our
table and at each each you know
different person whether it's the maitre
d or the waiter or the bus or whomever
it is
his name is mr patrick and my name is
sir and i'm like damn
don't know me do they they know him he's
mr patrick i'm just the guy with him
like is that your accountant friend who
is that okay all right so yeah but but
it was a great time it's great to see
you my friend yes my friend dan patrick
yes yes um
we thought the over under was how long
paulie 90 seconds before you mention
your dinner okay yeah so how where did
he go was he under 17 18 seconds oh 18
okay all right yeah i bet the under
buddy i'm gonna cash in
amy a couple nfl things
why do you think the nfl is
looking at reconsidering overtime
oh listen
because they
i think that they're doing it because
the media is pushing them to do it i
don't think they should do it
i think that there is i think sometimes
the nfl can be a somewhat reactionary
league
and you know when patrick mahomes got
screwed out of a chance to go to a super
bowl four years ago nobody cares because
the patriots get to go so there wasn't a
big push for it but when god forbid josh
allen doesn't get a chance to go to the
super bowl then all of a sudden we have
to redo things it's stupid lee the goal
of sports is to win in regulation if you
don't win in regulation you have failed
to achieve your goal fairness is no
longer my biggest concern like you have
you have failed to achieve your goal and
the idea that we can just act like
fatigue and injury aren't a big part of
this i think it's silly
the initial reaction he had when tyreek
hill announced he was going to the
dolphins from your chiefs was
well the initial reaction was i was not
pleased obviously but once i had time to
fully digest it and think about it and
see the return i'm okay with it i'm okay
with it for a number of reasons one is
the
we have about a 10 player list of over
the last few years
excellent player x traded for first
round pick and then some
and aside from the jalen ramsey trade
there isn't a single one that you would
say oh if you remove the quarterbacks
i'm not talking about stafford take
quarterbacks out of it you know position
player got
that you would say is a home run for the
acquiring team stefan diggs was a home
run for the bills but it was also a home
run for the vikings they got uh they got
justin jefferson khalil mack did not
work out for the bears jamal adams did
not work out for the seahawks uh laramie
tunsil has not worked out for the texans
so i think in the moment it sucks
because you lose an awesome player but
then when you get the you're not paying
the player
all that money and you're getting the
draft picks it can work out
and i get thrown in my face by your
favorite member of first things first
kevin wilds that's the other thing at
this dinner my god you couldn't stop
talking about how much he likes wilds
like hey buddy i'm here he's not sorry
he wouldn't respond to your text but
regardless set that aside wilds always
throws in my face the patriots is
patriots at the real dynasty this is a
move the patriots would have made
correct yeah trade tyrae kill rather
than pay him 30 million a year so i'm
okay with it yeah it's like richard
seymour when they traded him to the
raiders exactly what i said it is it's
not because they thought richard seymour
was done being a great player it's
because they thought that they could
that they could add more total value to
their team with the draft capital
acquired and with the cap space freed up
to fill in other holes i think their
offense i think if you have patrick
mahomes and an adequate offensive line
and they have now more than adequate
offensive line your offense is at worst
in a minus
and so fill in the holes elsewhere
but the rest of the afc west came up
well that is true
with that said there's that cuts both
ways so you have the broncos win right
now when right now trade all those picks
the raiders win right now win right now
trade all those picks well they sure as
hell better hope they win because by the
way i think the broncos and raiders
despite the moves of the third and
fourth teams in the division i think the
chiefs in charge still ahead of them and
if they don't win right now now they're
minus picks so the chiefs meanwhile
they're plus picks but the other thing
is this of course the other teams in the
afc west trying to catch up chiefs won
this division six years in a row that's
the that's four of holmes years and two
alex smith years and i i know it's like
trendy right now it's not trendy in
vegas vegas tells the chiefs is the
favorite but it's trying to be like oh
kansas city
are they gonna make the playoffs are
they the favorites in the division and i
would just ask people
if you take any division in football and
say one team has clearly the best coach
and clearly the best quarterback is that
team going to be the favorite in every
division the answer is of course yes and
the chiefs clearly have both he's nick
wright first things first co-host on fox
sports one i was wondering about the nba
now as we head towards the end of march
and we start to handicap how this is
going to sort out and yeah you can't
help but think about the lakers and i i
started to think about the lakers with
lebron usually has a four-year plan
wherever he goes
cleveland four years and then miami four
years back to cleveland now here with
the lakers
do you think that this four year is he
in for the long haul with the lakers
which means maybe one or two more years
well i think he's certainly in for the
lakers for next year i think after that
because you're right about the four-year
plans but he extended the contract of a
year or so right after the championship
and i think i i think two things have
happened one is he obviously was wrong
in pushing for russell westbrook and the
front office was wrong and acquiescing
if they actually thought it wasn't gonna
work that's what the front office is
there for um but i also think maybe
lebron underestimated
himself in that how long he was going to
be able
to still be playing at this level
because i think if he knew
after that year 19 i'm gonna win the
scoring title i'm gonna average 30 a
game that i could clearly still be the
best player on a champion if the right
pieces are around me i think he would
have given himself more flexibility
instead i think maybe he thought i'm
going to be phasing a new different part
of my career so let me let me make sure
i'm with a franchise that historically
is always trying to win immediately and
a player anthony davis 10 years my
junior
who you know what i mean can be the best
guy ad hasn't stepped up to that the
franchise hasn't stepped up to that
lebron's done his part and it's gotten
them what might be not even in the play
not even in the play-in and i have some
takes on that dan if you want them yeah
something funny so something's okay so
it's all nba voting time coming up and
by the way i still don't have a vote and
i was told by people that would know
well you've never worked for a you know
you don't work for a broadcast you don't
write for a newspaper hard to get a vote
then i hear yesterday ryan russell got a
vote
i'm sitting right here guys i'm sitting
right here no vote that's fine
so
my guy lebron james
win the scoring title this year and i
can already see it festering this idea
of oh
is he going to be in all you can you be
on the all-nba team if your team misses
the playoffs can you do it and to which
i would say
first of all every scoring champion ever
has been first or second team all nba
except for bob mcadoo who fell to dave
cowan's in terrible vote and kareem
that's fine that's first point second
point is this
last year's scoring champion didn't make
the playoffs either does anybody know
what it is anybody remember steph curry
was there a lot of steph curry slander
last year dan was there a lot of why
isn't steph curry carrying the lakers or
the wars no is it because oh he had so
recently won a championship no lebron's
won a title more recently than him
that's another thing i say about the
lakers i have these votes would be like
oh how long
does lebron get to bask in the
championship glow when does the
honeymoon end there's been one champion
crowned since the lakers do you know the
full list of people who have won a title
in the nba more recently than lebron
james the milwaukee bucks roster that's
it he's won a championship more recently
than everybody else people like oh man
honeymoon's over honeymoon just started
we're what just started the honeymoon
where'd you get that tone i mean you're
you're you're mariah carey you're going
up i know you this is this this is the
i only do this on your show i know
because i try to bring something to the
table something different i don't want
to make it just like all my other media
appearances
podcast i have the tv show like why
people are over saturated with nick
wright content so why would they tune in
especially for this and it's because you
get this version
i brought this up that whenever i bring
up mvp candidates and uh i i have bo
voted on the nba awards
but um
you know
not anymore because i left those
broadcast partners it was really a
choice of mine you know i wasn't working
at the mothership and i decided that i
mean i'd let guys like ryan rosillo come
in and maybe vote on this
no offense nothing against ryan but if
he qualifies how do i not qualify i
agree i recited did you see my vid i
recited every mvp in league history in
reverse order from jokic to 1960. i
screwed up on bullet bob pettit that's
it 59. that should be part of the
criteria but go ahead all right every
time i bring up mvps candidates then i
leave out devin booker
and i hear from the phoenix suns fans
and my point to them is
he is your best player he's not your
most valuable player because chris paul
is your most valuable player and i think
devin booker is unfairly
labeled characterized as just a great
shooter i think he's a great player
i don't think he's the most valuable
player on his own team
so last year i thought chris paul was
the most valuable player in the whole
league and i was ex just crushed by the
people that actually have votes saying
how dare you say anyone's more valuable
than nicola jokich then chris paul
played nicole yo gets in the playoffs
and swept his ass out and set that aside
so last year i was with you this year i
think booker has taken another step
and i think it's at least arguable that
he is because they played really well
without chris not quite as well as with
him and he played point guard some
but
the best booker can do
is fourth place or fifth place on
balance like nobody is even the sons
fans that are arguing he should be
included are just arguing they just want
him on the ballot and the guy who i
think is not getting included in the
conversation who i think shouldn't just
be on the ballot but has an argument
should win it is luca
what's the argument against luca the
mavs might be the three seed his second
best player is spencer dinwiddie his
second best player before the trade
deadline actively hated him and chris
dapps he doesn't have great teammates
around him he's what is he 28 9 and 9
like people like he started slow well he
must have picked up steam because on the
year he's 28 nine and nine so i don't
know why luke is not getting discussed i
think it's a pretty clear at this point
top six i think ja has played himself
out of it because he's missed so much
time because they're so they're 18-2
without him i think the top six in one
order or another is luca giannis embiid
jokic booker tatum i think booker has to
me earned consideration but just same
with tatum end of the ballot
consideration
yeah and then you have the celtics if
they're the number one seed in the east
and i got to give credit i know we
sometimes give too much credit it's like
well the best player on the best team
and then you got to put him in the mvp
conversation but i you know tatum
and that and they play defense too it's
not like a one-dimensional guy
listen i have been i i've been tatum
skeptical compared to
the other people because people are like
hey he's top ten player and i'm like
okay list them because you listen these
guys have 16 people in their top 10. you
got to actually like so tatum uh you
know tatum to me was a right on the cusp
of the top 15 along with booker and
donovan mitchell and trey young those
guys right tatum
what has happened the last six weeks is
all of a sudden instead of being 44 from
the field he's 54 from the field his
efficiency has skyrocketed and the
celtics
are 31 and 10.
since new year's day
well that's a half a season of a 60 win
pace so you have to get that's not a
small sample anymore yeah and so tatum
to me it's not just that they're winning
more he's playing better i still don't
totally trust them in a series and i'll
tell you this much their fans don't
trust them either because their fans
were all angry oh nick they're the ones
respect the celtics and then robert
williams went down and they're like oh
what oh we're screwed now i don't mean
to be rude robert was a nice player if
your championship hopes were robert
williams contingent then you didn't have
championship hopes fellas just letting
you know uh what is uh tell us about the
podcast the what's right with nick ryan
oh thank you for asking dan i appreciate
that uh it's a few times a week it's me
with my sidekick happens to be my son
who i told you quite a bit about about
that dinner i mentioned by the way
that's two over two and a half mentions
of the dinner so i went under on when i
did it i was gonna pay for dinner
because nick it always said oh i invite
you to the games and you know you never
want to be around me he pulls out a wad
of cash
so
so we're at a steakhouse and i go what
the hell are you doing and he's just
peeling off bill yeah paulie i think
that's a bit of a ball or move as a kid
say well he came in with a baller coat
on i know that i had a great coat like
it was almost a great coat like a denzel
washington american gangster type like
he came in he was a great coach yes it
was a statement it's a statement piece
it was it was it was a statement wad of
money it was bloodless
the coat was blood red like our steak
and yeah he came in and he meant
business there but he pulls out this wad
of cash and i'm going who pays with a
wad of cash
well let me let me tell you a couple
things the and what did i tell you you
were like what are you doing i was like
i'm leaving here and going to a poker
game so i need cash on me also i'm not
the greatest with budgeting so what i've
started to do is at the beginning of a
week i take out x amount of dollars
and when i'm out of them i'm out of them
no more credit cards for your old buddy
nick right we're paying cash on
everything we can we're a cash only
business not a lot of paper trail we
just got we and by the way people like
people respected and that waiter
appreciated he got his tip in the moment
he didn't have to wait for any card to
go through anything like that but to
answer your question about the podcast
it's me and my son it's a few days a
week and starting here in a few weeks we
are doing something i've been working on
for two years because i thought i was
going to write a book but instead i'm
doing it as this audio video series the
50 greatest players
of the last 50 years in nba history so
kareem's rookie season essentially to
right now the 50 greatest players ever
we're getting bernard king snub from the
top 75 list your your buddy nick
wright's got him sidney moncrief an
outrageous old [ __ ] from the top 75
list your buddies got him so we're gonna
do that counting it down how about that
all right i like it subscribe people
how do they subscribe
oh on uh you can subscribe on youtube if
you want to see
uh if you would like to just listen on
your favorite podcast platforms just
type in what's right that's right with a
w and i would say if i can just get 10
of dan patrick's listeners to subscribe
and you don't even have to listen guys
just hit the subscribe button i don't
really care if you listen i just want
you to subscribe then i'm i'm in there
and then all of a sudden but last thing
last thing
i thought you're going to tell him did
you tell paulie why i demanded to pay
my rationale do you remember yes i do
i wanted to pay so then i would be out
of the dog house the knick-knack dog
house like i i already i was good and
then he goes no no i'm gonna pay
because then you have to take me out to
dinner because i paid for this dinner
yeah obligated to a second i know i know
the old second dinner i know
i know yeah it's like when you go on a
first date with a girl and you leave
something at her apartment yeah yeah
that's exactly what i was doing paulie
that was exactly what i was thinking yep
so i'll see you soon and i'm getting the
wag you that time buddy yes no split
steaks kobe beef yep uh thank you all
right that's uh nick wright first things
first co-host fox sports one